on the hill today four the giants will
be the right-hander logan webb
he only went two for four yesterday had
an rbi double in the fifth inning
as he crushes one deep to left field
going back wade junior that ball's gone
[Applause]
gets the astros on the board first a
two-run home run his 12th of the season
that ball was destroyed
hanging slider and then mashed 105.6 off
the bat no doubt about it it's just only
a question was was it going to hook in
to foul territory but i don't think
there was much time for it to hook luis
garcia the starting pitcher today for
the houston astros
for the newest member of the orange and
black
benny second
third baseman number 23
chris bryant
[Applause]
struck him out
beautiful breaking ball from garcia you
take a look at that picture where he put
it in a 3-2 count you can see why he's
got the strikeout total he has
oh yeah
what a comeback at bat for luis garcia
got down to yashrenski 3-0
mike doesn't like that call but that had
the whole plate
he's out at first
he picked off mccormick
that's all you need is a little bit of a
lean one way
and a swipe tag from ruff
just like that
a fast runner that gets on to lead off
an inning to sit packing
three up three down including the pick
off of mccormick donovan solano 271
average
got him 96 mile an hour fastball to
close out the second inning
six and a half games ahead of the padres
here's the 2-2 it is poked up the middle
crawford to his left has it the quick
release to first got him one away
nice play brandon crawford altuve
lunging
and he got the bat on the ball and he
hit it so softly that it was a very
tough play but brandon crawford throws
him out more gold glove caliber defense
from crawford there one out
bryant struck out swinging his first
time and we mentioned how tough luis
garcia has been against right-handed
hitters
deep left field
it is a home run
chris bryant
in his first game as a giant
has hit a home run for the giants first
run of the day bryant
the giant
is what the sign said 2-1 houston so now
crawford stands in crawford grounded out
his first time up the 2-2 pitch crawford
hits a ground ball nobody's there at
second base send to right center field
that's a hit yostremski speeds around
third he'll score
and the giants have tied the game at two
the way the astros played their defense
there altuve was way out in shallow
right field but they kept correa
over on the shortstop side of the bag
here is darren ruff now
down the right field line that's going
to get down base hit
posey heading home tucker fires
and the giants have gone ahead
crawford over to third and after falling
behind darren ruff
comes through in the clutch three to two
giants i mean how good is this at bat
you mentioned it at the start of the
game he's been on fire
on the ground nice backhand play by
bryant
the throw is sailed though to first base
maldonado will head over to second as it
goes into the crowd
oh chris bryant on the nice backhand
play had some time but his throws sailed
and he'll pick up an error
there will definitely be an error it was
a very nice pick up on that backhand he
did a good job of standing up to make
that strong throw but just air mailed it
to avoid that scenario
on the ground solano will backhand it
kind of stumbled got himself up and
threw him out
and the hottest guy
in this lineup of stepping into the box
right now darren rough one strike pitch
swing and there's a high drive in the
deep left center field wayne back goes
alvarez at the wall and
[Applause]
it's a two rod homer for darren rock
five to two giants
a fifth inning home run for the second
day in a row for ruff
against a
houston right-hander grenkey yesterday
and garcia today
first and second nobody out back-to-back
base hits they will have the tying run
to the plate here diaz at second
mccormick at first
bonded
leon to third out
weird
it was as if maldonado just didn't want
to hit a double play
it is an unusual play i mean you just
don't see american league teams do this
very often but a nice play
from dominic leone to be able to come in
and get to this ball quickly he's been
hitting a lot of homers and they're not
surprised
in houston
high pop fly
a long run for yaz
he gets there
and they head out to be off balance
that short on alvarez double was only
the second extra base hit allowed by
rogers to a lefty this year ground ball
to the mound and they will turn two
jordan alvarez will score on the double
play it's now a five to three game
one and two
correa the runner at first rough on the
bag with him
chopped to the right side
solano
and the inning is over
they get three hits in the inning
on the ground diving stop correa gets up
to throw
in time carlos correa's done it again
what a defensive wizard he is
he is so much fun to watch over there at
shortstop this is a great series to see
defensive shortstops make some great
plays this is a key situation to keep
the giants off the base pass late in the
game 22 saves for jake mcgee a 2 2 8
earned run average
along the right field line he has on the
run again
he's there in foul ground
one away
nice battle good get there by magee
right field yaz going back
he squares up
two down
and that's exactly what jake mckee did
he just ran up here hit me fastball
owen to the count
struck it out swinging
another one even a higher still
at 98 miles an hour
and for jake mcgee another save his 23rd
of the year and for chris bryant
his first game as a giant he knocks in
the first run with a home run